no you were you were doing a good job of
supporting yourself and doing everything
right
exactly like i don't know what i did
wrong
but i lost everything not because of a
drug addiction or anything it was
it was just
it's not fair
all right loyalty hi loyalty where'd you
grow up where are you from originally
um i'm from nashville tennessee
tennessee
and tell me about your family did you
grow up with both your parents
um i did for the first part um
but my mom she was a heroin addict
i was born four months premature and
that had a whirlwind of like
different responsibilities that i had to
take care of throughout my life you know
like mentally um
challenges you know um
[Music]
i had both my parents yeah but my mom
she sadly
like died of an overdose i was 13 years
old
and shortly before that i did my first
shot of heroin
with her and
[Music]
my dad he passed away at 17 i was 17
years old
he died in a car accident
you had a rough childhood yeah
it played out a lot in my life you know
like
the choices i make are altered
and the feelings i feel are altered from
like the normal perspective like
society's
perspective of normal um i might look
normal
act normal but i don't feel normal um
i didn't have the the responsibilities
shown to me i didn't have certain like
morals and [ __ ] that i should know you
know and that should be placed in my
life
through my parents i i wasn't able to
get that because it was cut off at such
an early age how old are you now um i'm
25.
25. i just turned 25. and during your
childhood was there
any abuse of any sort
nah my mom she she did really well like
the first couple years of my life to
hide that you know but i really don't
remember that
um but she took care of me for the most
part um
made sure i went to all my doctor's
appointments she was a good mom
she just had an addiction so no physical
abuse
oh no yes just a mom who is
who's addicted to drugs yeah uh
whenever i lost her i lost everything um
my dad wasn't there for us neither one
of us he really wasn't a part of my life
like that
where did you go after that um after my
mom died yes
i went into state's custody
and i wasn't good enough for like foster
care
because i have mental mental problems i
have autism
it's a it's a moderate case you know
it's not it's not high or nothing but
it's just due to the premature birth
um i was born four months premature
um my mom had had overdosed and
she was gonna kill both of us so the
hospital like
did an emergency c-section and um
yeah save both of us
so you and i are on your own at what age
you you and i are on your own at what
age
13. well states custody they let me out
at 19.
but i felt alone i was alone you know
the state
they they only between 13 and 19 where
were you uh states custody
i was like in and out of like group
homes residentials
treatment facilities um but no no
parents
to say no i was my own parent
and were drugs continue continuing for
you after that
uh they were altered a little bit
because of the fact that i was in group
homes and [ __ ] but
there's ways to get that [ __ ] and pretty
easy
people you know not even what they're
doing but
um yeah not really i was pretty
pretty addicted um
11 years i i spent my life doing heroin
11 years of my life i'm 25.
that's crazy yeah so today you're you're
living where
um i'm on skid row how long you've been
here
about eight months i was living in
carson
i had moved out here with one of my exes
and
this was about three years ago and he
came out here for a job
and it was in construction for an agency
you know they wanted him to move
over to arizona so we swapped arizona
and i found an agency for me it was a
temp service
and i started working like daily for
them
and i was getting paid okay but
it just enough to get us by and then i
had
a job offering like and it was crazy
because it was like a lot of physical
work physical labor and it's a man's job
like i would i actually started um
i didn't have i don't have like a degree
or nothing like that like i just worked
solely off of what
my boyfriend had taught me and what the
temp
agency had taught me like through daily
things but i did everything from
flooring to concrete to
fences putting up drywall all kinds of
[ __ ]
sorry can i cuss sure okay um
yeah did you graduate high school i
didn't
i did not how far did you go um i do
have my ged though
i did get my ged but i didn't actually i
didn't even make it past the sixth grade
i dropped out whenever whenever my mom
died i i stopped everything that's why
they
had me for like uh what is it called um
unruly an unruly kid that's why i
couldn't go up for like foster
care or nothing it wasn't because i was
like
physically like homicidal or nothing
like that but
i was just a bad kid the government
portrayed me to be so now that you're on
skid row
how are you supporting yourself um
oh yeah yeah through the temp agency you
know i had a job offering
and of course my educational background
i do have my ged so
that helped me out a lot um and i
i bumped up to working not for the temp
agency anymore but i moved to
carson uh yeah i had a house
i i had a house for myself and my
boyfriend i had two cars
one that i i was paying for my own and
when i was paying for my boyfriend
i was really putting in like like all of
the you know and i enjoyed it i enjoyed
every moment of it
it helped me quit heroin it made me
a better person and sadly i lost all of
that eight months ago
um because of cover 19. i got
i got let off from my job and i couldn't
take care of myself anymore i wasn't
living off of no benefits from the
government and honestly i still don't
know how to do
any of the gr and [ __ ] like that i don't
get that i'm like here with nothing
because i don't know what to do like
nobody's ever like sit me down and told
me hey
you can do this for yourself you can do
this so if it hadn't been for covid
you'd be working still
yeah yeah i'm still my job is to have my
house my car
i'd probably still have my fiance but
wow i lost everything first it was my
job and then it was my house you know my
car
and then my fiance took off with me in
his car
so i had to pay for that too still
making payments on that
and i have no no money income the edd
stuff
um they had some kind of malfunction
somebody was using
some kind of something on my account and
i haven't heard nothing back from
so i don't know what's up with that and
i'm like
i shouldn't be doing as bad as i'm doing
right now
um and it's just crazy you know i lost
everything
like like like that like
everything i had to show for for the
past
twenty four years of my life
is gone in a matter of three months
i lost it wow and how are you supporting
yourself now
i'm not i'm i'm like
i feel horrible i've never been like
this down in my life like
i've always like took care of myself
um i've always had somebody that
that like cared about me around me and
now i just have
nobody um
sorry so um
it's it's it's it's pretty it's pretty
hard
especially being in in one of the
honestly the best and the worst place i
could be
to be homeless right now you know um
you selling yourself to guys that'll
that'll pay you
honestly um i did have a pimp
um not too long ago um
and it was just because of my new
addiction
and that's to to fentanyl you ever heard
of that
yeah i'm allowed to say that stuff right
sure okay yeah
a lot of heroinetics move over to
fentanyl um
i started doing fentanyl whenever i lost
my [ __ ] like
i started doing it heavy about six
months ago and
uh i've been going down here downhill
rapidly um lost a lot of weight
and and i care about myself you know
like like
my body's a temple you know but it's
obviously it's not too much of a simple
now you know
um
yeah i honestly i feel sorry for myself
and i shouldn't that's the last thing
that i ever want anybody to feel for me
you know feel
sorry for me feel bad for me you were
doing a good job of supporting yourself
and doing everything right exactly
like i don't know what i did wrong but i
lost
everything not because of a drug
addiction or anything it was
it was just
it's not fair do you have kids
i don't thank god thank god i don't have
kids
ah that'd be horrible do you have
friends
um other than street acquaintances
honestly i don't even have like
acquaintances um i have people that i
talk to
you know i don't kick it with nobody i'm
a loner you know
after the pimp situation um
i i actually i got abused by that pimp
um so i like took off
with a trick and you know i haven't seen
him since
i heard he's trying to find me but
if he does what can i do what is he
going to do
if he wants the money you have it should
one way
but what do you worry about most now
now what's going to happen next
um i wasn't i wasn't putting any thought
into that
until about a month ago um
i've just been pretty down now like i
don't know where to go
i don't know what to do i don't know
where to turn i don't know who to talk
to i don't know
i i don't know i don't understand it
you know i can't comprehend the fact
are you depressed that i'm like this
[Music]
i don't know how to get myself out of it
yeah really depressed you get depressed
anxious as well and all of it
but i tried to not show it those tears
you just saw
that's rare that's rare
do you feel shame about how your life is
falling apart
i don't i don't i don't feel shame i
don't feel
i don't feel embarrassed i i just feel
i just don't i just don't deserve it i
didn't deserve it
i mean it's my fault that i continued to
go down you know
like i could have done other things but
could have should have would have i
don't even know what i could have done
when it happened i wasn't thinking you
know i was i was
i didn't know what to do my life has
had honestly my life was given to me
on a silver platter even though i went
through all the trials and errors and
[ __ ] that i went through
it was personal personally a
blessed learning experience you know
everything i did it had a purpose it had
a meaning and
i learned from it i either
succeeded from it or i learned from it
um
good or bad what's the most important
lesson you've learned
honestly
i've learned that my my error
is that i do to others what i
want them to to do to me you know like
like treat me wise
um so you're kind to others
and i expect it and you expect that in
return
but i shouldn't you know especially not
down here
i guess my moral right now would be like
stay strong stay stay stay
stay put together as much as i can you
know like like
i don't really know i don't know
i don't feel like like myself right now
so i
i don't know what to tell myself i don't
know what advice to give myself i don't
if i did i probably would have done
something about it by now you know
i'm it's like i'm waiting i'm waiting
for somebody to to
to push me into a direction
or to tell me what to do i know nobody's
made to do that nobody's gonna do that
[ __ ] but
hopefully by by the grace of whoever
the hell is here
above me or below me
whatever um i hope they help me somehow
give me some kind of i still have hope i
have a little bit
but honestly like
being in these streets man it it's like
right now could be the last time i'm
breathing
i've seen people get killed right in
front of me i've seen
people get hit by cars and [ __ ] like
like
beating each other to death like skid
row
i've seen more on skid row than i've
seen in any horror film
um people are crazy man
these drugs are no joke you know
if i had any advice to give to anybody
it would be
not to take anything for granted i took
everything i didn't take it for granted
but
i didn't um
i didn't appreciate it the way i should
have
and i feel like that's maybe why i lost
it
the way that i lost it or maybe i was
just too blind to see you know
that there was a different opportunity
there that i
i wasn't able to see at the moment and i
lost
it's just a lot of like negative
thoughts about what i could have done
like not regrets
but
along the same lines
have you been in love before huh have
you been in love before
um
it depends what kind of love like in
love with somebody else or
i'm not sure um i don't think so
because the way i i
i still love myself you know but but
not as much as i i did
a year ago like i
i love myself i love myself and i know
what love feels like
and the definition of love i can explain
all of that
a year ago i could tell you that [ __ ]
like that like
i was so proud of myself i and i i
i assumed that to be the same kind of
feeling that i would have
towards somebody else a little bit
different but
i love myself so i know what it feels
like to have loved
but
i felt more lost than love
heartache
[Music]
what's your definition of love maybe i
can answer that a little bit better
that's a great question
there's so many types of love there's
romantic love there's
like you said self-love there's the love
you have for your children or your
family
and that's two entirely different ones
they're all very different and i think
my question to you was have you been in
a romantic
relationship that was significant
no no i've been i've been in a
relationship i was
i was engaged um were you in love
i feel like i fell in love if you have
to think about it you weren't
but i'm yeah because what i've been
there is no mistaking it i don't think
i've i've nothing
experienced that yet i don't think i've
i've been granted the gift of
experiencing love that a man could could
give me
or warming or whatever
i don't think i have because if i have i
i think i would be able to tell you
no you'd you'd know it if you had it
it's when it happens it's it's
unforgettable
and there's nothing that feels as good
but
yeah no i haven't but you haven't yet
and that's fine you're young
i'm scared to feel love not a lot of
people are not scared
fear of getting hurt fear of success
fear of
all these kind of things stops people
from
letting it happen
most of those emotions got cut off in my
childhood so
well loyalty i wish you the best of luck
down here you're in you're in
the worst spot you could have found oh i
thought you would not say you i'm the
worst person you've talked to
you're in the worst spot you could
possibly choose to
end up you have any advice for me
if you can figure out a way to get away
from the drugs
that would be a big one
getting away from this neighborhood is
key in doing that
finding employment and a routine that
can keep you on track
would be a great step he had that
yeah i know you did i know that's what's
frustrating about your stories that you
kind of had everything lined up were you
doing were you using heroin then
no because of my job i got tested like
regularly that's why so you were clean
and you were working and
everything was great yes and now you're
homeless i wasn't even smoking weed
a box of cigarettes would last me damn
near you do you blame covid for kind of
your downfall here i do
i do wow that's the only reason why why
the my job because it's like
government-based so
if if they laid off a bunch of people
a bunch of people got laid off because
koben yeah that worked for like
for the government i didn't work for the
government but i worked for somebody
that worked for the government
like a subcontractor um i suspect there
may be a lot of stories
some of the years a lot of people are
taking the hit because of covet
and hopefully they can relate to this
and it helps them somehow like
maybe they have some kind of advice i
mean definitely read the comments
you know maybe somebody's got something
to help me out with
you know i need it i need it
i need it
but i don't blame clovid for how i am
right now
right now is is solely because of me and
because of
how i pitied myself of how
i took the whole situation i shouldn't
have took it the way i took
it but i did and now i have to face the
consequences
that's that's a very healthy statement
you just made i think
it's not taking responsibility for your
situation is is the first
huge step yeah like i don't i don't
blame kobed for
making me another drug addict like no
i'm not like that
i see that that's me that's me that made
that mistake
but i do blame cloven for making me
homeless
[ __ ] all right thank you so much for
coming and talking with me i wish you
all the luck in the world
thank you you still have a great long
life ahead of you and
i hope so a couple lucky breaks and you
could be back where you were
oh yeah i hope you get that well thank
you for having me
thank you